LIGHTNING WILL BE BETTER
TONIGHGH
TAVARES ON DOORSTEP.
MARNER TO RIELLY.
HIS SHOT GOESS CHANCE.
AND VASILEVSKIY SEASON WITH 31.
TAVARES TO MARNER.
RIELLYTALL AT THE
LINE TO STAY ON SIDE.
COULDN'T REACH THE PASS. THE
PERIOD FOR THE LEAFS' PENALTY
KILLERS WITH A HALF MINUTE
REMAINING IN THE FIRST.AME ONE.
AND HAD A DEFENDERS.
BACK ON THEIR HEALS
FOR ENGVALL.
THAT GOAL THREE SECONDS LEFT IN
THE FIRST WAS, OKAY, PUT IT
BEHI TAKES A LITTLE SWAT
AT COREY PERRY AN HEADS TO THE
BENCH.
ONE, ENSUING.
LOOK AT THE FOCUS FOR MATTHEWS
IS KEEPING HIS FEET GOING.
STAMKOS DIDN'T FEEL THE PRESSURD
MATTHEWS.
HERE COMES ROSS COLTON.
IT CONSR
THAT LONG.
KILLORN CENTRES AND DAVID KAMPF,
BUBU POWER PLAY AND THEIR
INTENSITY IS THERE.
NO STICK FOR B
FACE-OFF.
BRODIE KNOCKED DOWN AT THE LINE.
GREAT KEEP BY KERFOOT.
ENGVALLL THE RECORD OF THE
LIGHTNING 14-0
AND MATTHEWS.
TRIED TO FLICK IT BACK FOR
GIORDANO AND A GIVE AWAY -- SEA.
BUT SEEMED TO HAVE A LITTLE
TROUBLE GOAL AND
AN ASSIST IN THE GAME. CERNAK A.
ALEX KILLORN CYCLELEN A SIMILAR.
QUICK PASSING PLAY UP F F MATTHS
47.6.
>> Chris: AND MATTHEWS WINS IT
CLEAN.D THAT'S KIND OF A
KNUCKLEBALLER THAT HAD ALL K KI.
KILLORN ALONG THE PUCK TO SPEEDE
PRESENCE OF MIND.
HE KNOWS THE THREAT OF HEDMAN IS
COMING BACK.
LO